واكد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي انه لن
يوافق على مطالب حماس وان اي صفقه تبادل
يجب ان تكون مشابهه للصفقه السابقه واضاف
نتنياهو خلال اجتماع لحزب الليكود انه لن
ينهي الحرب قبل القضاء على قاده حماس وان
هذا سيستغرق عده اشهر لا سنوات من جانب
اخر قال نتنياهو خلال تفقده قاعده لقوات
المدرعات في منطقه اللطرون غرب القدس ان
ما وصفه بالانتصار سيفتح الباب لتحقيق
مزيد مما سماها باتفاقات السلام
التاريخيه خلاصه سياستنا هي الانتصار
المطلق على حماس لانه ضروري لضمان امن
اسرائيل وهو السبيل الوحيد الذي يتيح لنا
تامين اتفاقات سلام تاريخيه اخرى تنتظر
على بابنا والانتصار المطلق يوجه ضربه
قاتله لمحور الشر الذي يضم ايران وحزب
الله والحوثيين وبالطبع حماس لذلك لا بديل
عن الانتصار المطلق
خ